not even one year ago I was a resident
now there's a TV show called the
resident let's get started
[Music]
it is shoe surgeons play their favorite
music when there are operating you guys
know this is my first surgery dr. Bell
no kidding
wait to get a photo make it quick get
into ok no no one's taking out their
cell phone in the middle of an operation
and taking selfies Oh tremor
[Music]
he's an artery on an appendectomy number
[Music]
he's breathing very heavily rightfully
so what's splattered on him maybe a
quarter of a leader
two liters is a lot of blood and that's
probably not two liters he has some
shaky hands may have hit an artery when
you hit an artery does splash like that
the first step during a surgery is to
get one of the tools called the hemostat
and basically it clamps off the artery
to get it to stop bleeding I'm assuming
this is someone's bad dream because
they're not following proper protocol I
have no idea why he's stopping CPR
nothing makes sense here okay you guys
told me the resident is the most
accurate medical show on television so
far this has been incredibly inaccurate
this gentleman's heart stopped in the
middle of the procedure because he was
losing blood they were supposed to get
blood and start the blood flow through
an IV they started chest compressions
they didn't follow the cardiac life
support algorithm of giving epinephrine
rechecking the rhythm after two minutes
and it looks like they called a time of
death after 30 seconds I think we can
all agree it was the mist Oh steve-o
Wyatt let this unfortunate situation
you're kidding right the patient woke up
his arm hit my hand
you left the blade in the field you
never should for surgery in the first
place as INR was adding up a range of
normal that's never gonna be no I'm
we're all on the same team here right
good he's trying to blame it on the
patient coming in with a high INR which
is basically the ability of the patient
in the inability of a patient to to clot
properly so if you have a very high INR
you're more likely to bleed out if this
happened I hope that the people around
me have the courage to speak up and say
something about it in fact one of the
biggest initiatives that have been going
on in hospitals over the last 10 to 20
years is to give nurses the voice and
the courage to speak up when they see
doctors especially senior doctors like
this gentleman who's a chief of surgery
who's been practicing for 30 years to
speak up and say no you've made a
mistake and we need to own up to it and
figure out what went wrong and how we
can prevent this in the future this is
awful this is an awful situation I have
goosebumps
honestly we toured is exposed I can name
each one it's a very cheesy way to turn
somebody on everything you thought you
knew about medicine is wrong all the
rules you followed will break
I have only one rule covers everything
I'm never wrong you do whatever the hell
I tell you no questions asked I can't
take this guy seriously he sounds like
he's from a western movie and he's like
welcome to the wild wild west yes in
reality medical school is quite
different from life as a resident
there's a lot that you think you know
about working in a hospital when in
reality you start working in a residency
you realize that you didn't know or what
you thought you knew was actually wrong
and you practice it in a different way
that's why those who get overly
confident by regurgitating facts and
figures really have their minds blown
when they enter the hospital and they
see the way medicine is practiced
because humans are very complex they
don't present like the way the textbooks
says they will present they don't always
give you a clear indication of what's
wrong with them it's a lot more of a
and figuring out what's going on the
heart of what he's saying is true the
way he's presenting it is way overblown
and dramatic my last resident had an
attitude too and you know where he is
now he's teaching eighth grade biology I
got him right you know what that means
it means I can end your career
just like that remove you from this
residency at any time for any reason and
if I do that no other residents do thank
you completely untrue senior residents
don't have the ability to get you kicked
out unless you do something just
horribly wrong and if you lose your spot
in a residency because you disagree with
a senior resident doesn't mean that no
other residency's will touch you again a
completely overblown statement and
untrue I guess for the dramatic factor
of the show this is dauber sloth he's
Croatian speaks no English
yes severe cauda equina syndrome what
are we worried about early paralysis hey
man what's the first sign of paralysis
anal tone stick your finger up his ass
normal procedure is to get an MRI thank
you so much for telling me about normal
procedure Cota Aquino syndrome is where
you have severe narrowing of the area of
the spinal cord where your nerves travel
through so you lose the sensation of
your lower limbs you lose the ability to
have proper anal tone
some people have incontinence where they
just pass their their bowels they lose
urinary control and just have urinary
incontinence meaning that they pee
themselves and if any of those things
happen you have to call 911 queena this
procedure this conditioner they're
talking about is a medical emergency
obviously one of the ways to test that
is to do a rectal exam and check the
sphincter tone but he's being really
rude about it
afternoon we need to explore your rectum
[Music]
back in the day we used to have
translators that lived in the hospital
I mean worked in the hospital now we
have really good intercom systems some
hospitals even have iPads that connect
you to another person who can be the
functioning translator the correct way
to do this is to not talk to the
translator and have them translate it
but talk to the patient normally and
have the translator somewhere behind you
or on the phone talking to them
translating so you're still having a
conversation with the patient not a
conversation with the translator that's
a very
important distinction to make I was
hoping this show wouldn't involve sex
but I'm striking out week by week
because apparently everyone's in love in
the hospital maybe I've just worked in
the wrong hospitals leukemic on chemo
fiance caught because she's shaking
uncontrollably she swiped the fever this
morning a hundred point eight also there
so commonly someone who has chemotherapy
performed on them they can develop
something known as neutropenic fever
it's what a specific type of white blood
cells very low and you have a fever it's
a very dangerous situation
broad-spectrum antibiotics meaning
antibiotics that cover a whole host of
different bacteria need to be given
right away in order to prevent the
person from dying because their immune
system is incapable in dealing with the
bacteria on its own so I think this is a
pretty interesting case already and I've
just seen like five seconds of it there
was some vomiting there's no blood in it
my skin was a week ago very accurate
presentation so far knowing when the
last chemo treatments very important
when judging what the next step of the
treatment plan is scared you're running
a fever just an infection chemo still
pushing your immune system I'll get you
started on broad-spectrum antibiotics
again I see the menifee to get your
fever down the cultures from both arms
here and she'll need a head CT okay
don't worry get this under control get
your both back home soon having a good
rapport with patients like that is very
important nurses and some doctors and
even people that are just spending time
in the hospital for a short period of
time are very somber when they're around
sick people especially chronically sick
people who've been sick for a long
period of time but in reality they would
love for someone to come in with a
little more lighthearted approach can
laugh with them make them smile I'll
always try and have a laugh with them
tell some jokes especially if I know the
family well and I think that makes a
very unpleasant experience a little bit
more bearable that's just my take on it
how do you get that cheeseburger check
looks like you haven't been following
your diet diets don't work have you been
taking your insulin I don't want to let
your name right here cuz I'm toes
killing me severe gangrene oh so a
gangrenous just really gross a
gangrenous toe could be so infected and
dead it's basically necrotic that means
dead tissue daddy can't fall off like
that obvious that's a little exaggerated
this smell is probably the worst part of
all of it because the bacteria once they
eat your tissue they release a very foul
smell it will light up the entire room
I'm not talking about you have to sniff
the wound as soon as you walk into the
room and there's gangrene present you're
gonna smell it that is very true 21 year
old girl history of IV drug use likely
endo those who use drugs especially
injection drugs they're predisposed to a
whole host of illnesses so this is a
common presentation unfortunately
especially in light of the opioid
epidemic that's going on right now when
you inject into your body anything
especially in a non sterile technique
meaning the needle isn't clean your skin
isn't clean
you're more predisposed to things like
meningitis endocarditis meningitis is an
infection of the pads surrounding the
brain and no carditis is infection of
the heart valves these are
life-threatening illnesses that can make
you act this way because bacteria is
festering in your body and unless it's
treated quickly and correctly you can
die and that's just talking about
infection think about all the other
things that could be going on when
you're under the influence of drugs it's
very possible that you're acting this
way as a result of an overdose from
simply the drug when a patient comes
into the emergency room and they're
presenting with this kind of outcry
screaming what we call altered mental
status AMS we have to figure out is it
related to the drugs is it because of
infection is it something more sinister
has this patient had a seizure there's a
lot of things that are happening
simultaneously in a doctor
mind so it's not an easy situation to
deal with but ER doctors are the
frontline in dealing with this and then
once the patient is stabilized and ready
to be admitted into the hospital
it's then goes to internal medicine
doctors like this gentleman or family
medicine doctors like myself if you walk
out of here without any antibiotics this
would kill you give us a chance we can
save your life I'll stay if you give me
three milligrams of dilaudid two if you
calm down I can't say what he's doing is
wrong because she's likely withdrawing
from dilaudid or opioids or heroin
whatever it may be in order to help her
condition it's possible that you need to
taper her off meaning give her smaller
and smaller doses more spaced apart of
the same chemical that she normally gets
high on Plus if it's gonna make her
reconsider and stay and get treated with
antibiotics for her endocarditis you're
saving her life some people may disagree
with his approach and say absolutely not
she's not getting that law did some will
say that there is a medical benefit so
that's why practicing medicine is an art
it's not a science because two doctors
can look at the same situation and have
different approaches for solving it I
understand what he's doing and I sort of
respected
[Music]
get a crash cart not getting a pulse
someone falls and they have no pulse
you call for help and without even
thinking about it you're pumping on the
chest chest compressions chest
compressions save lives I've said it
before chest compressions I'm gonna say
one more time chest compressions is the
first thing you do even if you have no
training in it start pumping on the
chest you're running the car I've never
run a code do you want an amp of bicarb
he's in charge page anesthesia when
you're running a code blue you're
following the advanced cardiac life
support algorithm it's literally written
out for you you give each person role
you do chest compressions you monitor
the medications you monitor the time you
monitor the rhythm and everybody has
roles after that there is a specific
algorithm you literally follow steps on
little cars that you can carry in your
pocket of when to recheck the rhythm
what medications to give what options of
medications do you have what dosage what
is the first question you ask you code
rhythm what's rhythm
pa pa is pulseless electrical activity
it basically means the heart has a
rhythm but you do not feel a pulse
there's some electricity going through
the heart but it's useless because it's
not creating enough of a muscular motion
and within the heart to create a pulse
to make the heartbeat peña is not a
shockable rhythm meaning you do not use
the paddles for that you use epinephrine
you use drugs use chest compressions and
you hope to get the patient back and you
wait for the rhythm to change into one
of the two shockable rhythms shoe shock
no we can't we will get me one event B
make those compressions harder and
faster so when you're doing chest
compressions you want to make sure
you're doing quality chest compressions
you want to push at least 2 inches deep
into the chest which sometimes can break
ribs it's a horrible sound to hear but
you're doing this to help resuscitate
the patient basically bring them back to
life so if on the off chance you break a
rib that's okay it does happen and
elderly folks much more than in young
folks you also want to do it to at least
a hundred beats per minute so if you
think there's 60 seconds in a minute
you're pushing a little bit faster than
once per second a good way to sort of
monitor if you're doing it right is to
sing the song in your head please stay
alive because that does go to about a
hundred beats per minute it's the
classic way that we're taught funny that
it's called stayin alive and we try to
bring someone back to life but that's
some of that raw medical edgy humor it's
been 24 minutes is time to come home no
this is my coat you gave me this coat
[Music]
we got a pulse
you see if don't laugh doing a code on a
young person for 20 minutes is not
unrealistic also not unrealistic to
recommend stopping the code because the
brain without oxygen for 24 minutes is
obviously very dangerous and even again
even if you bring the pulse back will
the brain work again you won't even know
until the person wakes up the first line
that one of the other residents tells
them as you saved her life in reality
that could be a great thing but also on
the other hand it could also be an awful
thing because she may just need to be on
a ventilator for the rest of her life
functionally brain-dead just her heart
beating in her lungs working because
she's on a machine so very difficult
situation to find yourself in you came
in here all right I should say over to
save lives but today didn't save a life
you saved a brain stem he didn't listen
to me did he do the wrong thing not
necessarily in this situation especially
because her family looked like they were
there this is the time to have a
conversation with the family very
quickly and explain to them what's going
on and explain the consequences of hey
if we bring her back at this point 20
minutes in she could could come back
with a pulse but also be brain dead and
help them decide what to do in the
situation allow them to make the
decision because you know they're her
next living kin some hospitals have a
cooling procedure that when someone
undergoes either a heart attack or a
sudden stoppage of the heart like she
did that they cool the body down which
slows them metabolic rate which can help
the brain survive a little bit longer so
this doesn't always hold true don't use
this as an application for your own life
or making decisions for your family's
life treat each situation on its own
talk to the doctors in front of you and
make the best decision that you can with
the information given to you at the time
what was rule 1 then do whatever you
tell me
no questions asked all we want to do is
help our patients but what they don't
teach us in medical schools there are so
many ways to do harm the first job of a
doctor is not to heal it's to first do
no harm because if you look at the
history of doctors in the past we've
made a lot of mistakes over treating
patients under treating patients
deciding what's right for our patients
and going against their own wishes I
think we've done a lot better in recent
years but there's still plenty of room
to go to improve is it were easy
everyone would be a doctor because this
is the best job in the world despite
everything because of everything
[Music]
[Music]
there you have it
the rezident season 1 episode 1 in the
books initial impression this shows
absolutely ridiculous this resident
while he's you know smart and has some
experiences he just does some crazy
things he's a cowboy in my eyes deciding
who lives and who dies I'll say the way
that they're talking about medicine is
accurate some of the medical terms that
they use or use accurately the
procedures somewhere in the middle 50/50
of their accuracy I think it's gonna
make for a fun show I definitely relate
more to this show because it's more
internal medicine and I'm family
medicine so I practice a lot of internal
medicine on my own as compared to Grey's
Anatomy which is a surgical show and I'm
less of a surgeon I like watching all
medical shows so if you have a show you
want me to watch or an episode of this
show or any other show drop it down
below in the comments and again the most
important thing you can do to help this
channel grow and get yourself more
content and better content is to
subscribe and not just subscribe but
click that little bell on the bottom to
make sure you get notifications when my
video first comes out as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]